[Music]
and trophy snatching news
oh I notice you do you do I know
everything
submitted by Nora from Connecticut I
knew she was gonna submit that article
where she from in Connecticut that part
in Connecticut you don't know know which
part though
Davenport yep exist is a Davenport
place called Davenport Connecticut I
want to get better it doesn't exist
yeah it sounds like it exists that's why
I sent that answer to him that sounds
how would you help nobody looks good
main city of Connecticut to have in Port
Connecticut [ __ ] there it is oh
it exists no that's someone not
someone's last name would work it
weren't [ __ ] there's no Davenport
Connecticut yeah there's got to be one
sitting back well if you just like
that's everyone [ __ ] that place wait
what's the biggest city in Connecticut
[ __ ] it
can we just make this article about
Connecticut yeah what the [ __ ] is going
on you never get to talk about
Connecticut I know what is in
Connecticut known for for connecting
people
no but connected people are cutting them
either way I had a Cambodian friend that
came from Canada
I want people from Connecticut to be
like yo JK you guys shouldn't talk about
kinetic if you guys don't know about
Connecticut because that comas gonna
have like zero thumbs up please fly me
out there and then I don't know don't
kill me
a series of previous mug shots have
surfaced of the man who is accused of
stealing Frances McDormand Oscar oh no
another oh this be please if one wonder
stealing the Oscar if you didn't earn it
like what the [ __ ] cares I mean that's
cool as hell don't steal an Oscar is it
I think there's almost nothing cool way
someone just stole Francis's Oscar you
just want one right yeah so she won one
for Best Actress for three billboards in
Evin Missouri and during the the
Governor's Ball which of the Oscars what
I'm just thinking of what would you do
with it like I can like cuz I come you
know how we near the grocery store
you could probably sell it on the black
market ducks I'm sayin like do you know
how you're at the grocery store
sometimes and then a minivan pulls up
and guys like hey man you want to buy a
stereo yeah he always had the stereo and
it's pretty cool like it's like it's
like yeah it's like a big minivan pulls
up you're outside of a drugstore it's
like hey man you want to buy Frances
McDormand Oscars I wonder if it was like
a salty person who didn't like her
speech I got a white white all the
ladies got a stand-up is there video
there is a video so this dude is he was
Terry Boyle at the Governor's Ball so
when France isn't right after she got
her trophy engaged engraved yeah great
that's when like she left it on the
table and that's in this Terry dude she
was targeted or he was just trying to
steal an Oscar that day she was like he
was like I'm stealing Oscars that's what
I want to know but apparently he does he
does like get into a lot of like
celebrity-type I know how I got it you
do huh yeah so as they were all walking
in he was in a tuxedo and he looks he
dressed the part and then in her
entourage he just like got in there and
he was like acting like he was talking
to them he was like waving to people too
and then he just with her crew he just
snuck in passing so he just smooths Mike
I think he just acted like he needed to
be there so he just gave off that vibe
that he belongs there
yeah even when he once he got the Oscar
he was acting like it was it so just
Frances McDormand for those you guys you
know and this is the video that they
found on Facebook of this fool claiming
that this trophy is your real baby
my team got this tonight
my baby I'm a pop he have to show the
world that he's stolen Governor's Ball
baby awarded with big groups small ones
icon for sound mixing or whatever you
know you know if you're part of the crew
that's right the last one for sure did
you see when he walked out out of the
place - yeah and then there was this one
photographer that was like even it's
like there and they were just like
questioning yeah because he's seeing all
the wrong things I don't see this [ __ ]
this is mine this is mine is anyone
going to congratulate me say this [ __ ]
everybody who actually got an Oscar
they're not even holding it they just
have it there they're like all right
yeah I'm so disappointing cause it to
get in that's pretty good like he acted
suave yeah the party [ __ ] played the
role and then when he gets the Oscar he
blows it yeah man just takes me out of
the scene I thought it was more way more
professional like I thought it was like
a super thieving dope like but this did
it almost seemed like he was drunk swipe
it put it inside can you imagine anybody
who won an Oscar being like I won this
will you please congratulate me is it
just I would immediately be like that's
not yours for some reason he looks like
a white man doing blackface I don't know
he looks like an old white guy doing
blackface to me I don't know why that's
he was claiming that he wanted for being
a producer like best producer and then
I'll just for do say that's not in the
category that's the kind of trash that
they sell in Hollywood Boulevard yeah
best producer award
you know the did he really think he
could get away with this like what
thing it was only afterthought or
anything that he said not that I know of
like that has been coming out of his
mouth cuz he was still in jail but the
crazy thing with this guy though it
doesn't seem like he even cared if he
got caught or not would you do this
right and this plan was a good call I
always liked it when their plans when he
walked out of that Governor's Ball thing
like there's a bunch of paparazzi right
and like he comes out like holding it
and like he's trying to pose for
pictures too so it's like very public
yes that's I think racy well that's why
I think maybe his plan was to get caught
because then you get the notoriety
everyone knows your name from right like
we all do know his face and his name on
his IG hero oh my god this reducer a
listen attainment journalist TV film and
music producer all like in his bio
yeah like the bio when the editor actor
TV host UN Ambassador oh and now he
could add thief to all of that how many
followers Olympian doctor police officer
baby seal yeah and so like bees and so
it's surfaced all of his previous head
shot or not head shot look mug shots
thank you his previous mug shots from
1999 to 2002 he got arrested seven times
good does not age man why does he look
like seven different black guy he looks
like seven different black guys yeah
look he got lighter in a darker contact
on this one it looks like you're [ __ ]
with the character creator in the video
yeah yeah yeah yeah exactly
like this shade that shade this shade
and so he's multi-talented huh yeah like
I say his face doesn't look real it just
looks like a white dude that did
blackface or something photos with
celebrities on his IG he is crazy like
Halle Berry and Kristen Stewart see
who's this guy like why does he look
like Charlie Murphy with a hat why does
Kristen Stewart look so uncomfortable
why can't he look into the camera he's
crazy
oh well you imagine how many other crazy
people like sneak into these things or
somehow get access yeah
events are so big like like I said I've
been to a couple like my Oscar parties
but like you know where there's other
actors and execs there and there's so
many actors who don't know who the [ __ ]
people are they immediately suck up to
you because they think that you're
somebody that might give them a job it's
the saddest [ __ ] thing I've ever seen
in my life well I think though but I
think the point is like because it's
high-profile people the security is like
amped up like crazy so like to get past
even how did you get in you've met the
wave you know somebody to something it
might happen because it's just
ridiculous dude why is security tighter
at VidCon in this like if you're an
adult person at VidCon and you try to go
somewhere and you don't have the proper
colored badge you're [ __ ]
you can't get through hello Fox oh yeah
it's like hi I'm an adult I'm not trying
to take these with people I literally
hate everyone here can I just go to the
bathroom in their regular place it's
like no you know they're like sorry sir
you might be a [ __ ] fan Yeah right
and I'm like no I'm an adult I'm not a
fan clear go they even have videos
YouTube videos of people that sneak into
a major events and they'll tell you
their entire process how they did it
they're just like printing badges out
cuz like people that do get legit badges
they'll post them on Instagram and then
people are able to recreate it yeah out
of being Shady
what depends on the shading is because
if you're an art thief you're cooler
than [ __ ] yeah those guys are the
coolest people no that's what I was
picturing for this doing like those
[ __ ] laser laser dodging [ __ ] in the
[ __ ] industry or you get that suction
cup thing that you put on the side of
the wall or Fiza stethoscope and you're
like that one's kind of old-school I
mean that's a little you know we've all
seen that they always have something in
their mouth yeah I also like having an
look at some special case for the art
right it folds up somehow whatever
and cool man they roll it up yeah they
roll it up put it in the tube so if you
have ever seen the Mona Lisa in person
man it's like this big yeah yeah it's
like that big that's it yeah well we
shouldn't have told them we should wait
for him to see it for himself and yet I
mean you guys saw it you my god I like
looking at I like it I just wasn't
expecting it to be that small what do
you like what do you like about it
it's the morally sits history dude yeah
hey people between that [ __ ] like is
Justin Bieber though I was lying this
[ __ ] Leonato then dude check that is
[ __ ] nothing man nice nice [ __ ]
over ring what did he do Dave one thing
he did is people like to be that they
the balcony like all the inventions and
things that he's done like Mona Lisa's
not one that he's known for I'm like
yeah how about he tried to build fly
machine maybe have you seen that [ __ ]
bicycle helicopter that he made man but
I rather have that on this of this plane
he's actually being known for be lose
you get that [ __ ] like propeller
thing that looks like pick a fight was
that funny because I could even remember
Lee that's Michelangelo you know I do
love is that because of advances in
science I should we know more than that
guy did oh yeah how cool is that
yeah [ __ ] that guy right oh pretty time
[Music]